The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
In our last two
lectures, we've been
talking quite
theoretically about what
we mean by spanning vectors,
dimension, vector spaces.
Today, what we'd like to do is
add some computational know-how
to our bag of knowledge.
And let me say at the outset by
way of a reinforcement of what
we've already said
in the study guide,
much of the material
in this block
is very difficult if
you're not used to it.
And we have already
reminded you,
but let's do it again,
watch the lectures,
get as much out of
them as you can,
do the exercises, which
hopefully will cement down
many aspects of the lecture.
And then if certain things
still aren't crystal clear,
watch the lecture a second time.
Hopefully, you may not even
have to watch the lecture
the second time,
but try not to read
too much into the lectures.
This is material, which
I think that once you
get the first insight, you must
then really work hard and do
a lot of exercises.
But at any rate, let's go into
today's lesson, which I call,
Constructing Bases.
And by way of review,
let's see what theory
we've had going
into today's lesson.
First of all, given
a vector space, v,
with certain elements, alpha
1 up to alpha n, the set of n
elements, alpha 1 up to alpha
n, is called a basis for v,
provided two things happen.
First, the alphas must span
v. And secondly, the alphas
must be linearly independent.
And, again, if this
gives you any trouble,
think in terms of the
naive example of the plane
or three-dimensional space.
For example, in
three-dimensional space,
i, j, and k span
three-dimensional space.
And they also happen to
be linearly independent.
At any rate, what
we then proved was,
that if alpha 1 up to
alpha n is a basis for v--
and don't be blinded
by the alphas, now.
What we're really
saying here is,
that if you have found a basis
for v, which has n elements,
then the following
things must be true.
One, any set of more
than n elements,
for example, any n
plus 1 elements of v,
are linearly dependent.
Again, in terms of
three-dimensional space, what
we're saying is, if you
have four or more vectors
in three space, those vectors
may or may not span v.
But the thing that we're
sure of is that they
must be linearly dependent.
You can't have more than three
linearly-independent vectors
in three-dimensional space.
Secondly, fewer than n
elements cannot span v. Again,
in terms of our
three-dimensional example,
no two vectors in three space,
can span three space.
In other words, then, a
basis has two properties.
If you have too many vectors,
you cannot have linear
independence, and
if you have too few,
you can't span the space.
So what is it, then,
that a basis must have?
If one basis has n
elements, every basis
must have n elements.
Again, by way of review, why?
More than n couldn't be
linearly independent.
Fewer than n could
not span the space.
So every basis for
v has n elements
once we know that one
basis has n elements.
Now, this, of course, does not
mean that any set of n elements
will be a basis, again, in terms
of three-dimensional space.
Suppose, for example, that
I take the following three
vectors of
three-dimensional space.
Oh, heck, let's say
i, j, and i plus j.
Those are three vectors,
i, j, and i plus j,
but they only span
two-dimensional space.
The trouble with
i, j, and i plus j
is that they were
linearly dependent.
You see, all we know is
that every basis for v
has n elements.
It does not mean that
every set of n elements
will be a basis for
v. However, what
is true is, that
if we have a set
of n linearly-independent
elements, or else
a set of n elements
which span v, then
if either of those two
criteria are obeyed,
then the set of n elements
will be a basis for v. Again,
in three-dimensional
space, if you have
three linearly-independent
vectors in three space,
they will be a basis.
They will automatically
span the space.
And if you have
three vectors which
span the space in
three space, they
must be linearly independent.
That's all we're saying.
In other words, to say that
the dimensions of v equals n
is unambiguous.
In other words, if we define
the dimension of a space
to be the number of
elements in any basis,
then what we're saying is
that that is unambiguous.
That once one basis
has n elements,
all bases will have n elements.
And now, with respect
to a particular basis,
what we're saying this.
Suppose we know the
dimensions of v is n,
and we have a
particular basis for v,
say, u1 up to un, a particular
basis that we single out,
then with respect to that basis,
each vector, v, in the vector
space, v, has a
unique representation
as a linear
combination of the us.
In other words, if the
us are a basis for v,
a particular vector
in v can be written
in one and only one way, as a
linear combination of the us.
Which means, you see,
that relative to the us,
v may be written unambiguously
as the n-tuple c1 up to cn,
where that's an abbreviation
for c1, u1, plus, et
cetera, c1, un.
And in this case, we also
write that v is equal to--
and to indicate
that we're talking
about the n-dimensional
space, v, with respect
to a particular
basis, u1 up to un,
we simply enclose the
set of basis vectors
in square brackets.
In other words, this
expression is read,
v is being viewed as the
n-dimensional space that
has u1 up to un as its basis.
And unless otherwise
specified, every time we
write an n-tuple in
v, it's understood
that that n-tuple
is being abbreviated
relative to the
basis u1 up to un.
And I think, again, the
best way to illustrate
this is by means of an example.
And, in fact, the
remainder of today's lesson
will be one example wherein
we will take one problem
and try to look at it from as
many different points of view
as possible so that we get a
broad spectrum as to what's
involved in constructing
bases, looking at n-tuples,
and how the n-tuple depends
on the basis, et cetera.
So the example I have in
mind is the following.
Let's suppose that.
All I know is that I have a
four-dimensional vector space.
What does that mean again?
It means if the
dimensions is four,
that any basis
has four elements.
Let me now pick a
particular basis, which
I will call u1, u2, u3 and u4.
And then notice
that notation now.
I'm saying that v is the vector
space, which has u1, u2, u3,
and u4 as a basis.
What that means
is, if I now elect
to use the 4-tuple
notation for v,
that unless anything is
said to the contrary,
it means that that 4-tuple is
relative to the vectors u1, u2,
u3, and u4.
For example, let's suppose
I was to say to you,
describe the subspace
of v spanned by the four
vectors alpha 1, alpha 2, alpha
3, alpha 4, where alpha 1 is
the 4-tuple 1, 1, 2, 3, alpha
2 is the 4-tuple 2, 3, 4,
5, alpha 3 is the 4-tuple
3, 7, 6, 5, and alpha 4
is the 4-tuple 4, 5, 9, 9.
Notice that what I'm
really saying here
is that alpha 1 is 1u1 plus
1u2 plus 2u3 plus 3u4, alpha 2
is 2u1 plus 3u2
plus 4u3 plus 5u4.
In essence, what I'm
saying then is what?
Once I've specified
a particular basis,
every 4-tuple notation is
relative to that basis.
And by the way, what do I mean
by being vague over here when I
say, describe the space?
What I mean is, for example,
is the subspace all of v?
In other words, we know that
the dimension of v is four.
I have four vectors.
If those four vectors
are linearly independent,
they will span all of v. I guess
an equivalent question would
be, therefore, are the
alphas linearly independent?
I can make this even more vague.
I can say, if w doesn't
equal v, what does w equal?
In other words, what subspace is
spanned by the vectors alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3, and alpha 4?
Now, what I'd like to do
is to introduce to you
at this time a rather nice
computational technique.
It's nice for two reasons.
The first reason is that it
gets the job done very nicely,
which is perhaps the
best reason of all.
The second reason,
which is also very nice,
is the fact that we've already
had the technique before.
Keep in mind the following
property of spanning vectors.
If we have a set of vectors and
we talk about the space spanned
by those vectors, notice
from our previous homework
exercises that we have
shown, that if you replace
any member of that
spanning set by itself
plus a multiple of any other
member of the spanning set,
you do not change the space
spanned by those vectors.
Oh, again, by means
of an example--
because as I say,
this sounds very
difficult from an
abstract point of view--
but if you use three-dimensional
space as an analogy,
as a reference
point, I think you'll
see more clearly what
these things mean.
For example, i, j,
and k are a basis
for three-dimensional space.
i, j, and k span
three-dimensional space.
Suppose I replace i, or for the
sake of argument, by i plus 3j.
Look at the three vectors--
i plus 3j, j, and k.
Those three vectors
span the same space
as i, j, and k, namely, all
of three-dimensional space.
In other words, i plus 3j and
j are non-parallel vectors
in the x, y plane.
Consequently, they spend
the entire x, y plane.
And then with the k vector,
all of three space is spanned.
So the idea is, that if ever
we replace a vector by itself
plus a multiple of any other
factor in the spanning space,
we do not change the space
spanned by the vectors.
And my claim is that this
suggests the row reduced
matrix technique.
Now, why is that?
Well, the best way
to see this is let's
write, as a coding system,
the alphas as a matrix.
In other words, what
we'll do is is we
will label the columns of our
matrix, u1, u2, u3, and then
the rows of our matrix
will simply be 1,
1, 2, 3, 2, 3, 4, 5,
3, 7, 6, 5, 4, 5, 9, 9.
In other words, in terms
of our code, we have what?
Alpha 1 is 1u1 plus 1u2
plus 2u3 plus u4, et cetera.
So this is my coding matrix.
Now, what did we do
when we row reduced?
For example, to get
a 0 in this entry--
remember our old technique?
We said something like,
let's take the second row
and replace it by the second
minus twice the first.
In terms of our
coding system, this
says, let's take the spanning
vectors, alpha 1, alpha 2,
alpha 3, alpha 4, and
let's replace alpha 2
by alpha 2 minus twice alpha 1.
You see, we are replacing
alpha 2 by alpha 2
plus a scalar multiple-- the
scalar happens to be minus 2,
but that's irrelevant-- plus
a scalar multiple of alpha 1.
So the space spanned
will not have changed.
In other words, if I now go
through this row reduction,
what do I do?
I get 0s every place here.
How do I do that?
I replace the second
row by the second minus
twice the first, the third
row by the third minus 3
times the first, the fourth
row by the fourth minus 4 times
the first.
In terms of the coding
system, what am I doing?
I'm replacing alpha 2 by
alpha 2 minus twice alpha 1.
I'm replacing alpha 3 by
alpha 3 minus 3 times alpha 1.
I'm replacing alpha 4 by
alpha 4 minus 4 times alpha 1.
When I do that, my resulting
matrix looks like this.
See, notice now what's
happened is these columns
are still u1, u2, u3, and u4.
But notice now, that whereas
this vector here is still
alpha 1, the vector 0, 1,
0, minus 1, in other words,
what, u2 minus u4,
is no longer alpha 2.
In fact, what is it?
How do we get this row?
It was alpha 2
minus twice alpha 1.
In a similar way,
this would be what?
0, 4, 0, minus 4.
But it's also what?
Alpha 3 minus 3 alpha 1, and
the vector 0, 1, 1, minus 3
is alpha 4 minus 4 alpha 4.
What we're saying is
these four vectors
may not look the same
as our original vectors,
but the thing that
we're sure of is
that they span the same space.
Now, at this point, let
me pause for a moment
and try to give you some
pseudo motivation as to why
I'm doing this.
You see, in the same way
that we solved systems
of linear equations,
when we said
that the same
system of equations
could be represented in
different ways, in other words,
two different systems could
have the same solution set,
but one of the systems was
easier to solve than the other.
See, one thing I'm saying over
here is that, somehow or other,
these four vectors look
perhaps a bit simpler
than these four
because of the fact
that I have 0s
appearing over here.
Well, I'll go into that
in more detail later.
The other thing is this.
Suppose, by row
reducing this way,
suppose I were to eventually
wind up with the 4
by 4 identity matrix.
In other words, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0,
1, 0, 0, 0, 0, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0,
1--
what would that
matrix represent?
Notice, in terms of this
coding system that 1, 0, 0,
0 would just be u1.
0, 1, 0, 0 would just
be u2, et cetera.
In other words, if
by row reducing this
I could ultimately wind up
with the identity matrix,
that would say that
the space spanned
by alpha 1, alpha 2,
alpha 3, and alpha 4
is the same as the space
spanned by u1, u2, u3, and u4.
But by definition of the
us, those four vectors
span my entire
four-dimensional space.
In other words, if in
row reducing my alphas
I wind up with the
identity matrix,
that will be proof, in
terms of my coding system,
that the alphas span
all of v, because they
will span the same space
as u1, u2, u3, and u4.
So maybe that's a more immediate
reason for proceeding the way
we're going.
At any rate, what
I'm going to do now
is to continue on with
my row reduction scheme.
In other words, what will I
do now in terms of reduction?
I will replace the first
vector here by the first minus
the second.
In other words, I'm
replacing alpha 1
by alpha 1 minus
this vector, which
is alpha 2 minus 2 alpha 1.
The important point being what?
I'm replacing a spanning
vector by itself
plus a scalar multiple
of another one.
In any event, going
through this operation
what I will end up with now is
the following 4 by 4 matrix.
And you see, again,
what I'm saying
is that the 4-tuples 1, 0, 2,
4, 0, 1, 0, minus 1, 0, 0, 0, 0,
and 0, 0, 1, minus 2 span
the same space as alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3, alpha 4.
Now let me keep
emphasizing that.
Even though I said
a 4-tuple always
means with respect to
u1, u2, u3, u4, unless
otherwise specified,
I think I will always
specify it so we make sure that
we get this idea hammered home.
Now, here's the first key point.
My dream of having this matrix
row reduced to the identity
matrix is now shattered.
Why is it shattered?
The third row is already
all 0s, so I can't possibly
get a 1 into this position here.
In other words, I can no longer
hope to get the identity matrix
here.
But this tells me something
much more than that.
In other words, even failure
is success in this situation.
Namely, the fact that
this is a 0 vector
tells me that the space--
the space spanned by alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3, and alpha 4
is certainly the
same as the space
spanned by these four vectors.
But one of these
vectors is the 0 vector,
and the 0 vector spans no
space, as we've already seen.
In other words, the 0
vector is always redundant,
because any scalar
multiple of the 0 vector
is still the 0 vector.
So that doesn't change what any
other linear combination would
be.
So I immediately know now that
the space spanned by alpha 1,
alpha 2, and alpha 3 can't be
any more than three-dimensional
space.
In other words, it's also
spanned by these three vectors.
By the way, let me
just continue to row
reduce this for the
sake of argument anyway.
In other words, let me
now replace the first row
by the first minus
twice the fourth.
Or if I delete this,
twice the third,
but that's not important.
If I do this, notice
that the matrix I get now
is 1, 0, 0, 8, 0, 1, 0, minus
1, a 0 row, and then 0, 0, 1,
minus 2.
Let me give the three non-zero
vectors here special names.
Let me call this vector
beta 1, this vector, beta 2,
this vector, beta 3.
And what does that mean?
It means what?
That beta 1 is u1 plus 8, u4.
Beta 2 is u2 minus u4.
Beta 3 is u3 minus 2u, 4.
In other words, this is
beta 1, beta 2, and beta 3.
What do we know about beta
1, beta 2, and beta 3?
Because they were obtained
from the matrix of the alphas
by row reduction, they span
the same space as alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3, alpha 4.
In other words, the
first thing we know
is that the space spanned by
alpha 1, alpha 2, alpha 3,
and alpha 4 is not
four-dimensional space,
but rather, it's
the space spanned
by beta 1, beta 2, and beta 3.
By the way, that
immediately tells me,
since beta 1, beta 2, and
beta 3 span my space, w,
that I'm looking for, that
the dimension of that space
can be no greater than 3,
because 3 vectors span it.
Now, at this stage of
the game, the question
might come up, what's so
great about the betas?
Why do we have the betas
rather than the alphas?
Do the betas help us at all?
And my claim is, making this
metaphysical for a moment,
if you just look at what the
betas look like over here, just
look at what the
betas look like,
forget about the u4
component, notice
that the betas without
the u4 component
look like the identity matrix.
See, 1, 0, 0, 0, 1, 0, 0, 0, 1.
My claim is that the betas are,
indeed, a very special basis.
And let me show you
what I mean by that.
What does it mean for a vector
to be in the space spanned
by beta 1, beta 2, and beta 3?
Well it means that that vector
must be a linear combination
of beta 1, beta 2, and beta 3.
Let me write down that linear
combination in the form
x1 beta 1 plus x2 beta 2
plus x3 beta 3, where x1, x2,
x3 represent arbitrary
constants here.
By the way, don't be upset
that I've used xs now
for the first time
instead of cs.
I've essentially
done the same thing
that we did when we were dealing
with arrows in the plane.
When we were talking
about a typical arrow,
we refer to it as
being xi plus yj
rather than refer to
it as being ai plus
bj to indicate, somehow how or
other, that we had arbitrarily
chosen the constants,
the coefficients.
It's sort of like in algebra.
There's no law that says, when
you have a constant, that you
couldn't call the constant
x, or if you have a variable,
you couldn't call
the variable c.
But somehow or other,
when we see a c,
we assume it's a
constant in algebra.
When we see an x, we
assume it's a variable.
The xs are just thrown
in here to suggest
that I'm looking at all linear
combinations of beta 1, beta
2, and beta 3.
And now, watch how beautifully
the form of the betas
comes to help us now.
Let's look explicitly to see
what x1 beta 1 plus x2 beta 2
plus x3 beta 3 really is.
Let's come back to
what our betas were.
To multiply beta 1 by x1 means
that we multiply each component
by x1.
So this will be
what? x1, 0, 0, 8x1.
We multiply each
component of beta 2 by x2.
That's 0, x2, 0, minus x2.
We multiply each
component of beta 3 by x3.
So I'll get 0, 0, x3 minus 2x3.
Notice, again, that these
components as 4-tuples
are relative to the us.
In other words, x1 beta 1
plus x2 beta 2 plus x3 beta 3
are the three
4-tuples given here,
where it's understood
that the columns values
are u1, u2, u3, and u4.
Now, I want to add these up.
If I add them up, I add
component by component.
Here's the beauty of that
row reduced matrix form
that yielded the betas.
Notice, that when
I add these up,
x1 appears only in
the first vector.
There are 0s every place
else, x2 in the second,
x3 only in the third.
Notice, that when I add
these up, I get what?
x1, x2, x3, 8x1
minus x2 minus 2x3.
In other words, any
linear combination
of the betas in terms of the
us has a very interesting
representation.
Namely, x1 beta 1 plus
x2 beta 2 plus x3 beta 3
is simply x1, u1 plus
x2, u2 plus x3, u3.
Then plus 8x1 minus
x2 minus 2x3, x4.
By the way, as an aside,
notice that I can now
very quickly show you that the
betas are linearly independent.
Namely, for linear
independence, notice
that I want to show that
the only way this can be 0
is if all the xs are 0.
But notice that since
this combination comes out
to be this, the only
way this can be 0
is to have 0s every place.
That says 0 must equal x1,
0 equals x2, 0 equals x3.
In other words, writing this
out in more detail, x1 beta
1 plus x2 beta 2 plus
x3 beta 3 equals 0
means this, which in turn means
that x1, x2, and x3 must all
be 0.
That proves, in
particular, that the betas
are linearly independent.
And therefore, my
space, w, not only
is spanned by beta 1,
beta 2, and beta 3,
but they are a basis.
That's why I write the
square brackets here.
And so my dimensions
of w is actually 3.
And by the way, let me show you,
again, what this thing means.
It means that, you see,
if something isn't w,
If it's written as a
4-tuple, all I have to do
is know what the first
three components are,
because the fourth
one is expressed
in terms of the other three.
For example, the u1 cannot
belong to my space, w.
Why?
Because u1 has x1 equal to 1,
x2 equal to 0, x3 equal to 0.
And this tells us what?
That when x1 is 1, and x2
and x3 are 0, x4 must be 8.
In other words, the only
member of w that begins with 1,
0, 0, is 1, 0, 0, 8, and
that's exactly what beta 1 is.
In other words, I
leave it for you
the check that u1, u2, and u3
do not belong to us space, w.
Well, so much for that.
Let me review now very
quickly what we've shown.
These betas are a
rather remarkable basis.
In other words, I claim
that beta 1, beta 2, beta 3
is a natural basis
for w, you see,
much nicer than the alphas.
Why is that?
Well, let me pick
any 4-tuple in w.
Let me call it x1, x2, x3, x4.
My claim is that once I know
that that 4-tuple is in w,
I can write down the linear
combination of the betas
that this vector
is by inspection.
Namely, what I just showed
was that that 4-tuple is what?
It's x1 beta 1 plus x2
beta 2 plus x3 beta 3.
Or equivalently, if
you want to see it
in terms of the 4-tuple of
notation in terms of the us,
the first three components
can be chosen at random,
and then the fourth
component is given by this.
And by way of a
quick example, notice
that as a 4-tuple
alpha 1 was what?
It was 1, 1, 2, 3.
In other words, it was u1
plus u2 plus 2u3 plus 3u4.
Notice that because the
first three coefficients were
1, 1, 2 relative to the
betas, the coefficients
are also 1, 1, 2.
In other words, I can write
alpha 1 as the 3-tuple 1,
1, 2, provided I
tacitly understand here
that I'm making reference
to the special betas
as being my basis.
You see, in other words,
referring to the alpha 1,
alpha 2, alpha 3, alpha 4
that we're talking about,
just drop the fourth--
in terms of the 4-tuples, drop
the use of four coefficient
and just write down
the remaining 3-tuple.
In other words,
alpha 2 is 2 beta 1
plus 3 beta 2 plus 4 beta 3.
Alpha 3 is 3 beta 1 plus
7 beta 2 plus 6 beta 3.
Alpha 4 is 4 beta 1 plus
5 beta 2 plus 9 beta 3.
You see, the betas
are a very nice basis,
because they're
that special basis
that once I know
what the vector looks
like as a 4-tuple with
respect to the us,
I can immediately write down
what it looks like with respect
to the betas.
Let me give you another example.
Suppose I just pick at random--
well, it's not picked at random.
I picked one that works here.
But let's suppose I just
take the 4-tuple 2, 5, 3, 5,
and I want to know
whether that's in w.
And by the way, again,
let me remind you
just one more time that
4-tuple stands for what?
2u1 plus 5u2 plus 3u3 plus 5u4.
Does that 4-tuple belong to w?
The answer is, it
belongs to w if and only
if it's equal to what?
2 beta 1 plus 5 beta
2 plus 3 beta 3.
That's the beauty of that
special basis of the betas.
Well, 2 beta 1 is
simply 2, 0, 0, 16.
5 beta 2 is 0, 5, 0,
minus 5, and 3 beta 3
is 0, 0, 3, minus 6.
Recalling, of course, that
beta 1 was 1, 0, 0, 8.
Beta 2 was 0, 1, 0,
minus 1, and that beta 3
was 0, 0, 1, minus 2.
So again, this is
all with respect--
as 4-tuples with
respect to the us.
If I add these up, I get what?
2, 5, 3, 5, which is exactly
the vector I'm dealing with.
So 2, 5, 3, 5 belongs to w.
In fact, another way of looking
at this is once the 2, 5,
and the 3 are given as the first
three components, the only way
that the 4-tuple
can belong to w is
if that fourth component is 5.
In other words,
again, looking at this
from one more point
of view, remember over
here we showed that the fourth
component in terms of the us
had to be eight times the first
minus the second minus twice
the third.
And given 2, 5, 3, the only
way that can happen is what?
8 times 2 minus 5
minus twice three
and that happens to be five.
Now we come to the home stretch.
And that is, knowing
now what the basis looks
like in terms of the
betas, we come back
to a more crucial question.
And that is, look it, we
were given alpha 1, alpha
2, alpha 3, alpha 4.
Those were the vectors
that we were given.
Maybe for the problem
that we're dealing with,
it's important to
have everything
relative to the alphas.
So now what we're saying is,
knowing what 2, 5, 3, 5 looks
like as a linear
combination of the betas,
how can we conveniently express
that as a linear combination
of the alphas?
And again, the answer comes
from row reduced matrices.
In other words, all we're
going to say is this.
Look it, we know what
this vector looks
like in terms of the betas.
It's 2 beta 1 plus 5
beta 2 plus 3 beta 3.
Suppose we could now express the
betas in terms of the alphas.
See, sort of like before
with the matrices.
We sort of want to
talk about inverting--
interchanging the
roles of the vectors.
Here's what I'm saying.
Look it, we already
know from over here
that alpha 1 is beta 1 plus
beta 2 plus 2 beta 3, et cetera.
Let me do the following thing.
Let me write down
an augmented matrix.
The first three
columns will stand
for beta 1, beta 2, and beta
3, and the last four columns
will stand for alpha 1, alpha
2, alpha 3, and alpha 4.
Notice that I can write alpha
1 by two different names.
It's 1, 1, 2 relative to
the betas and 1, 0, 0,
0 relative to the alphas.
And similarly, alpha
2, alpha 3, alpha 4
can be represented as I've
written these things over here.
Now, what have I done?
I have written each vector
in two different ways--
one relative to the betas and
one relative to the alphas.
If I now row reduce
this matrix--
notice that I'm
dealing with vectors--
whatever vector
I get by one name
must be the same vector with
respect to the other name.
In other words, if I start row
reducing now in the usual way,
this matrix becomes this matrix.
And again, to show
what we're saying is,
this is just another
way of saying what?
That, for example,
this is beta 2,
and this says that the vector
beta 2 is the same as alpha 2
minus 2 alpha 1.
This happens to be--
oh, let's look at this one.
This is beta 2 plus beta 3.
And that's the same as what?
Minus 4 alpha 1 plus alpha 4.
And you see, what I'm
going to try to do
is row reduce this part
here and hopefully be
able to express the betas
in terms of the alphas.
So what I now do is continue
my row reduction technique.
And you say, if I do that,
my next step gives me this,
and this is a rather
remarkable thing.
Because you'll now notice
that reading my first three
components here, this tells
me that the third vector,
at least in terms of the
betas, is the 0 vector.
By the way, what's
another name--
see, what I'm
saying this is what?
0 beta 1 plus 0 beta
2 plus 0 beta 3.
What's another name
for that vector?
It's 5 alpha 1 minus 4
alpha 2 plus alpha 3.
In other words, as
an aside, 5 alpha
1 minus 4 alpha 2 plus
alpha 3 is the 0 vector.
Therefore, by transposing, alpha
3 is 4 alpha 2 minus 5 alpha 1.
And now, indeed,
we have not only
seen that the alphas
were linearly dependent,
we have found the redundancy.
That in the order given, alpha
3 is a linear combination
of alpha 1 and alpha 2.
By the way, just as a
computational check,
notice by our definitions of
alpha 1 alpha 2 that 4 alpha 2
is 8, 12, 16, 20.
Minus 5 alpha 1 is minus 5,
minus 5, minus 10, minus 15.
If I add these two,
I get 3, 7, 6, 5,
which, as you will
recall from looking
at our definition of alpha
3, is, indeed, alpha 3.
At any rate, what I'd
not like to point out
is that what this
piece of information
tells me is that this is the
redundant piece of information.
That what we really know is that
the betas do not need alpha 3
to express them.
Why?
Because the betas
could originally
be expressed in terms
of alpha 1, alpha 2,
alpha 3, and alpha 4.
So you don't lose track of that.
The space spanned
by the betas is
the same as the space
spanned by the alphas.
So, in particular,
each of the betas
must be a linear combination
of the alphas by definition
of spanning space, just
as each of the alphas
must be a linear
combination of the betas.
So I know that the
base can be expressed
in terms of the alphas.
But now, I've seen that
alpha 3 is redundant,
because alpha 3 can be
expressed in terms of alpha 1
and alpha 2.
So what I now have is what?
That beta 1, beta
2, and beta 3 can
be expressed in terms of
alpha 1, alpha 2, and alpha 4.
See, notice that with
this row deleted,
the alpha 3 column
has all 0s in it.
And by the way, if I now finally
complete my row reduction,
you see, I wind up with this
matrix, this 3 by 7 matrix.
And this tells me,
in particular, what?
How to express beta 1,
beta 2, and beta 3 in terms
of the alphas, in
particular, beta 1
is the 4-tuple 7, 1, 0, minus 2.
And notice now, I
don't want to say this
as a 4-tuple in the
following sense.
Notice, if I now were to
write 7, 1, 0, minus 2,
that would be redundant.
Because now I'm talking relative
to the alphas, not the us.
The important thing is what?
That beta 1 is 7 alpha 1
plus alpha 2 minus 2 alpha 4.
Beta 2 is minus 2
alpha 1 plus alpha 2--
well, just that's all it is.
And beta 3 is minus 2 alpha
1 minus alpha 2 plus alpha 4.
This tells me that
the betas are a basis,
the alphas weren't the
basis, but alpha 1, alpha 2,
and alpha 4 as a basis.
Getting back to our
original problem,
now that we're expressed
beta 1, beta 2, and beta 3
in terms of alpha 1,
alpha 2, and alpha 4,
knowing that 2, 5, 3, 5 is 2
beta 1 plus 5 beta 2 plus 3
beta 3, we can
now replace beta 1
by what it's equal to in
terms of the alphas, beta 2
terms of the alphas, beta 3--
well, beta 2 is equal to
minus 2 alpha 1 plus alpha 2.
Beta 3 is minus 2 alpha 1
minus alpha 2 plus alpha 4.
Replacing the betas
by what they're
equal to in terms of the alphas,
I wind up with this expression.
And I find that 2, 5,
3, 5 is the following
linear combination of alpha
1, alpha 2, and alpha 4.
Namely, minus 2 alpha 1 plus
4 alpha 2 minus alpha 4.
And I leave it for you to check
that, if you actually take
alpha 1, alpha 2,
and alpha 4 as given
at the beginning
of this example,
you will indeed find that this
linear combination, minus 2
alpha 1 plus 4 alpha
2 minus alpha 4,
is indeed the vector 2, 5, 3,
5 that we're talking about.
Well, as I mentioned
to you, I want
you to get an overview of
what we're talking about.
There are going to be
plenty of exercises on this.
Let me just
summarize, or at least
give a partial summary,
of what we have really
done computationally
in this example.
We started with
four-dimensional space, v,
relative to a basis
u1, u2, u3, u4.
We picked four vectors--
alpha 1, alpha 2, alpha 3,
alpha 4-- in that space,
and asked to see what space was
spanned by those four vectors.
And we showed that there were
three very special vectors--
they had a very nice form--
called beta 1, beta 2,
beta 3, such that v had--
the w had beta 1, beta
2, and beta 3 as a basis
so that the dimension w was 3.
We also showed in this
particular problem
that not only was
the dimension three,
but once you picked the u1, u2,
and u3 components arbitrarily,
the u4 component was
determined by these
in this particular way.
In other words, another
way of saying this
is that w consisted of
all linear combinations
of the betas, where these are
the same xs that appear here.
And as a case in
point, we showed
that a particular vector,
2, 5, 3, 5, belonged to w.
That when we wrote that
vector relative to the betas,
that vector was 2, 5, 3.
When we wrote that same
vector relative to the alphas,
it was minus 2, 4, minus 1.
Notice, by the way, a
very important thing here.
You see, every single time that
we talked about two vectors are
equal if and only if they were
equal component by component,
when we wrote them as
n-tuples, it was assumed
that the basis never changed.
Look it, forget about the
betas and the alphas here.
Look at the 3-tuple 2, 5,
3 and the 3-tuple minus 2,
4, minus 1.
Certainly, they are
different 3-tuples,
but they happen to
name the same vector,
because one is a 3-tuple
coded relative to the betas
and the other is a 3-tuple
coded relative to the alphas.
In other words, once we
pick a particular basis,
we must remember that
our coding system
is relative to that basis.
If, for some reason, it becomes
convenient to change the basis,
then we have to be
very, very careful
and remember that, therefore,
our coding system has changed.
And that's why, in most advanced
applications using vector
spaces, a great
degree of difficulty
comes in, because
what we've done
is we've changed basis vectors.
And people who are so rigid that
they keep visualizing that you
are using the same n-tuples
over and over again
get confused as to how
two different n-tuples can
name the same vector.
Well, at any rate, I think
that's more than enough
for one session.
Do the exercises very carefully.
Try your best.
As I say, if you have any
trouble after the exercises,
review the film again.
Listen to the lecture again.
And what we will do
next time is pick up
some consequences
of vector spaces
that tie-in with other
aspects of the course
that we've already studied.
But at any rate, until
next time, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.